big thanks to our sponsor betterhelp
it's easy and affordable online therapy
you can get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com trash tuesday that's
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday for 10 off you guys it's
no secret we love
liquid death's new flavored seltzer i
mean listen to that
oh that makes me feel good and liquid
death is available at your local amazon
target albertson safeway 711 or sprouts
and you can even rock liquid death merch
their collection is very chic and cool
you can go to liquiddeth.com trash to
get free shipping on their crazy limited
edition merch and apparel that's
liquiddeth.com
trash to get free shipping on limited
edition merch and apparel liquid death
death to plastic murder your thirst i
want to let you know uh a very special
event is coming up july 11th marks the
first day of my new live interactive
spotify show it'll be exclusively on
spotify it's audio only
it's called don't bore me with annie
letterman because you know what i've
been entertaining you guys all this time
it's time for you to entertain me it's
going to be a fun hang
super interactive and i cannot wait so
follow me on tik tok instagram and
twitter to find out more details about
that and get ready for july 11th baby is
going down
you can also see me live doing stand up
my favorite thing to do in the world i
can't wait to meet you afterwards and
sell you shirts and sign your shirts and
and
maybe i'll get some sunglasses i can
sign them it's small but i can do it i'd
love to rematch you with all my slugs
so i hope to see you out there i will be
next in austin texas
at the
vulcan comedy
gas company
vulcan gas company
on one night it'll be july 29th i can't
wait to see you guys can't wait to meet
you
it's going to sell out so get your
tickets fast i'll also be in springfield
missouri august 19th through 20th
pittsburgh september 9th through 10th
which means i will be flying home on
september
you remember
so come out to that one and then later
you can see me in tempe arizona and
caluso california at the casino that's a
one night or two it's gonna be so fun
come gamble with me we're i'm gonna then
be in kansas city irvine san jose
michigan daniel beach florida
so many other gigs go to
andyletterman.com
shows
daddy your butt is so bubbly you should
see those thighs i just saw in the
bathroom
they are
spray tanned
put a little filter on that one
you guys
we're back
you guys girl time
uh-oh scary well i do have my period but
also it's just like no don't give it to
me this is the first time we've recorded
since roe v wade was overturned so that
was
i watched the news i didn't know for
like so late into the day
todd's like how you feeling i was like
about what
i was like i'm having a great day what
are you talking about
it's the creepiest thing that could ever
happen thank you so much to our country
yeah thank you guys you know what i
decided i decided this on stage last
night i'm just going on the boys side
i'm done with you [ __ ] i'm done it's
too hard i'm not fighting for us it
would be so much easier you guys are
stupid [ __ ] and you're stupid nasty
tuna [ __ ] and it's so disgusting you
love murdering late term abortion by the
way are there really actually late term
abortions is that even a real thing
but who can yeah who cares dude i don't
want to cry when i abort it
if it comes out crying i'm on their side
it's so scary and weird and i don't know
how to feel or how to cope other than
just laugh through the pain
i had a really crazy memory i'm about to
tell a [ __ ] up story are you ready
yeah let's get it going
there was a girl in my high school i
hope it's about you having a late term
abortion
she was hooking up with my brother's
friend he was in college already he came
home for the
summer they were hung up she was a
senior
she graduated
they hooked up she goes to school
maybe it was over christmas break or
something she goes to college for the
first year she comes home for
either thanksgiving or christmas
she's wearing baggy clothes
she goes back to school
her mom smile i i'm sorry i always laugh
this is a horrific story i laugh at
funerals
no one you know
you just go to them
that's our next photo shoot that's the
billboard
i love that it's just pixelated uh dead
body behind us no bobby i think
pioneered um selfies at funerals like 10
years ago i could see bobby having that
power
he would um i the he went to a funeral i
don't remember which funeral but he took
a selfie with a casket
um remember my funeral please right but
i think that that people are more open
to the idea of documenting funerals the
same way they're doing weddings now they
have like a videographer so it's like
you know it's another celebration of
life
and just does the dead person get to
decide i want to pick my photographer
annie leibowitz you better be available
i only want a photographer if people
respect my wishes and in my final form i
would like to be taxidermized i want to
be mounted on a wall no i do doing that
at wrestling stands in a single oh my
god always fighting
yeah is that legal can we i want to be
like this i want to be like oh i love
that we're still here now i know my goal
is to have you both taxed or meet and
keep you so you have to kill us first
oh look at you i would love to have you
guys sitting in my living room every
morning like this isn't that cute not
talking for once
the only time you get a sentence out oh
my god and then i sit and i record a
podcast where i just tell you guys about
my day i'm in annie i'm like annie
you're so quiet today
i'm still blinking i've you taxidermy
too early you come back
and nerves are still going off i want to
try that's why hell actually that's my
actual to not be able to talk to not be
able to talk is my abs even the hiccups
i'm like how can you kill the hiccups i
want to stab them to death the heck of
that annie finish your story
oh so you're gonna regret that is
wearing bags so she leaves she goes back
to school her mom smells something in
her room smells something
yes no
no
we are living in the dark ages so it's
appropriate there was a baby there was a
baby in the in the there was a dead baby
in the basket a girl you know her
laundry yeah
what did she do she
went back to school
she was like i guess in denial like
didn't know what's happening so then
they pressed charges against her but she
got off because
they couldn't prove if the baby had been
alive when it was born or not and she
just went crazy i mean she was like
18. this is so sad and by the way this
is a story that should be told because
this is the kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
will be encouraged yeah because you
can't get abortions in certain states
now
yeah
i just and then she i did find i i
looked her up i found her and she seems
to be have moved
forward in life
she's a partner it's good to know no
kids
it's kind of like those kids okay okay
but guys you know sometimes you just
bring up a thing
no i'm not kidding you like that's the
kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that that the
supreme court wants
to happen if they don't want people to
be able to have abortions i saw my
friend mike lawrence last night who is a
comedian he's funny he's a monster he
looks like he crawled out of a garbage
can
he got an autism diagnosis he goes he
goes
he was like i'm so finally def i'm so
happy to finally be diagnosed with
autism like i diagnosed you 10 years ago
brother
i was your doctor annie i told you i saw
the shifty eyes i knew what was up
but he um i saw him last night if you
walk into a doctor's office in india
you can't even tell your symptoms i'm
just like let me guess
i use a crystal i'm like i have a shaman
i do ayahuasca to figure out what's
wrong with you
but he so i was talking to him last
night and he was having trouble adopting
him and his wife
their adoption had fallen through twice
and i was like well here's a positive
you're going to be able to get a kid
he's like 100 i think it's gonna be he's
like i'm gonna have my pick now yeah so
there's some positives adopt people that
are having trouble adopting will what
have more options no
annie listen i'm trying to find a little
juice of joy
and joy juice i appreciate you offering
that up to him as encouragement but i
here's why i i disagree
because my mom got pregnant when she was
and
i'm pretty sure she didn't want to keep
it like i feel like she low-key dropped
that but the guy who got her pregnant
was from a catholic family and
immediately told everyone so she had no
choice
and
she obviously when she had the baby like
yeah you carry it for nine months you
love it you want it
and she said that like five days after
she got home from the hospital i think i
might have told the story in here but
it's more relevant today five days after
she got home from the hospital the
hospital called her and they're like do
you we know you're very young do you
want to give your baby up for adoption
and at that point
she my mom just started crying she's
like hell no like this is my baby so
it's like
it doesn't just become easy to like give
it up for adoption once you you're a
woman you're you go through that like
you're biologically designed to fall in
love and keep it yeah i don't know
but
so that's your sister the point is the
point is my mom wanted to support my
sister there's so many people in your
family that wanted to be aborted
it's really we're seeing a theme here
and for you to look like a
tall grown sucked out fetus is really
disrespectful to them to just see you
saunter in on thanksgiving just throwing
what they could have been in their face
i have a really good um story i'd like
to tell
in front of the supreme court yes okay
we'll be the judges well you guys are
you're putting [ __ ]
okay you guys know that um i have i'm an
accidental brother [ __ ] right yeah
it's never been with intention i don't
actually lust over siblings surprise
but can i if abortion go ahead your
sister's so hot i'm so attracted to her
sorry i just wanted to say that can i
also interject that a lot of like the
really good porn videos happen to be
under the category of like step siblings
yes and it's like i try to like just
pretend that wasn't the label and watch
it but then sometimes they'll say like
you're my stepbrother i'm like yeah but
i just want to say i'm an i accidentally
jerk off to that and i didn't mean to
thank you esther that makes me feel a
lot better nobody likes you he's like
such horseshit i've never seen a fake
sibling
is not at home i don't have a brother
okay i have a twin brother no i'm just
kidding
it happens
um well i'm gonna tell you this you're
not gonna accidentally jerk off to this
story okay um when i was 19
um i hooked up with a boy who i then
after we hooked up after we had been
dating um and after
it wasn't until after i got pregnant by
him did his grandma find out and then
sit us down and then say
um yeah you might want to terminate that
pregnancy because that baby is going to
have a tail
because
he might be your brother
so supreme court i'm telling you i would
have had
a little gargoyle with a tank supreme
court really what we want to say is when
a child is born
named kalila we need to separate her
from all of her siblings because
they are she's kind of like she's
literally so hot
that kenny you're doing it again you're
doing it again which is not how she's
ugly so no she's normally she's hideous
she's just a person she's just a person
she's not someone that even brothers
lost enough
i would have had to live a life
like having to explain to my child with
a tail why my mommy's so much hotter
than them
[Laughter]
why i chose to
[ __ ] my brother this is one of the worst
cases to take to the supreme court a
tail they're going to go what speaking
of a tail you're really weaving a tail
here
what the hell is this
i'm just saying the chances of you know
in breeding are sometimes a little weird
and off is that why you're worried about
your eyes being far set because all your
kids are going to be even more far set
because they're going to be half
yes and at 19 i was obviously a dumb
drunk so they would have had like for
sure would have had some type of like
fetal alcohol syndrome i would have
taken you home if you were drunk i would
have taken your sloppy ass i'm just
[ __ ] raped you
oh that's awesome
not a pedophile
i can admire the the story okay we have
to call esther hot and kalila ugly
esther doesn't like it you guys anyone
that tries to protect esther we're
giving her esther exactly what she wants
i know this [ __ ] okay but honestly
esther um during um the tiger belly live
show when you mounted me and then here's
here's what hurt my feelings can i tell
you what hurt my feet yeah tell me all
about i wasn't there i was in [ __ ]
west niagara
having a great time
she i was like esther like are you okay
to like kiss me you know consent all of
that and she was like yeah let's just
cheat a kiss because she didn't have her
tongue scraper it's because i never want
to be like
i don't want to make you uncomfortable
me uncomfortable i asked for the kiss
and you rejected me
and yes i was impregnated by my brother
this is what are abortions like in i
can't imagine in the philippines
abortion
you can you can't imagine what it's like
there's a coconut involves
shelf there's no coconuts at your
stomach you know it's so funny they used
to sell this uh very dangerous cocktail
outside of a lot of churches in the
philippines they were very cheap it made
women very very sick and ill and a lot
of women um eventually like would if
they survive they would have like a lot
of like ramifications to their
reproductive system um and but they
would the irony is that it was always
sold outside of churches it's like this
little cocktail and you just had to know
where to get them it was it's scary this
is horrible it's like if you're a horny
lady and you want to [ __ ] it's like the
government wants to punish you and make
you have a [ __ ] child yeah why can't
we just be
[ __ ]
like
like our mamas frida slots guys
i know
but also it's i feel like your life is
written out like a porn fantasy
yeah you would think that no i porn is
really in the eye of the beholder isn't
it
i mean you're sick you know you are
you're the director of a porn you're
playing you are you
that's exactly what you are you just
can't imagine she click clacked her
little nails on set and her little tiny
body came in and was like you there legs
up over your neck do some squats what's
going on here
pull the you each pull one side of the
labia you go here we i could really make
like an amazing porn like it could come
from inside of my heart why don't you
just have your own you know they're
spiegler you are obsessed with porn i'm
not obsessed you have been obsessed with
porn star since i met you she's always
like trying to befriend them in the
creepiest way like leave them alone
like i watch you every day they're like
we don't need more of those okay i don't
need more of those i have a question for
you esther when you befriend them does
it change the way you look at them
because let's say for instance when i
got pretty close to asa
not
play available don't worry there's no
acting happening oh really right here
there is
so before you become oh that's not
attractive
sibling porn no it's not but
oh i would say that to answer your
question i at least take a break from
watching their videos if i know them i
need a break right okay that makes sense
so before you come back to it later
so before you got to know brielles and
you were just jerking off
at her and then you became friends with
her and then it slowed down
something like that okay gotcha
something like that oh my god
look at her she doesn't reveal anything
secret the secret [ __ ] over here
what's your bracelet
balanciaga i want the cheapest thing on
the side it's so cute how much was it i
think 250. oh i buy that it's so cute
friendship bracelets yes we're going to
make trash tuesday friendship places
slow yes
sluggies
can we model them after that yes we can
i really like that that looks like a
very cheap production why don't we just
copy all of the are we allowed to say
that out loud yeah why don't we just
copy and re-brand all the model our
stuff off of of our favorite designer
stuff yeah hell yeah
i would rather wear that than the
dessert because i was someone was
reading the comments that was in my own
head
and
someone made a really good point they're
like don't get the louis vuitton uh
chain because
it's like cheap shitty metal they're
like go to the jewelry district and
[ __ ] drop cash on like a nice
yeah gold pieces but a lot of times with
those metal ones they're less because i
have very sensitive skin so certain
types of metals do kind of cause more
eczema on my my neck has been green from
this for two months
it's not a designer it's like yeah but i
didn't think it was fake i don't know
but this i got my niece this like
beautiful locket
matching ones and it was so cute she
loved it my younger niece was like my
whole life i've wanted to lock it i'm
like i'll get one in four years my whole
life
she's like i always wanted a lock and
i'm like you'll get yours relax but i
got this for reese and then
it's like already turning me green so
now i'm like i'm gonna have to get a
replacement
lock it
i know it's sad because we we like just
started being able to afford jewelry so
we don't know like what turns you green
and what doesn't but i also don't wanna
like it's weird with like the money
situation because i am happy that i'm
earning money i'm happy i get to buy
these things i feel like i'm going
through like a superficial stage i don't
think this is gonna be my whole life
it's just like fun to finally be able to
do this but with my family they don't
want me to buy my ten-year-old niece
like a
like thing over a thousand now they
would never want that so it's like i
have to make sure i'm getting them like
a responsible gift that's not gonna
be too much pressure to lose or yeah
that doesn't matter
so it's just weird but i was like on are
you garbage the podcast and i started to
feel guilty i was like wait should i
stop bragging about making money i'm
like i think it's funny i don't know
but whatever um and i was we were
talking about and i was feeling like i
was bragging too much and i go yeah i
put the down payment down for my family
vacation stuff like where is it and i
was like the poconos and they just
started laughing in my face like we
thought you were going somewhere like
big and i'm like
i've never heard of the poconos i bet
it's fantastic
yeah it's going to be great
yeah
to take a whole family outside of the
united states is a big it looks really
nice there no i'll do it i want to i'm
hoping to be able to pay for everyone's
college and stuff
i shouldn't say hoping i'm going to pay
for everyone's comments speaking of
family vacations carlos is in cabo right
now he flew first class
i'm like must be nice [ __ ] with his
whole family yeah they all met in cabo
they do all have money huh i didn't know
that doctors really made that much money
i thought that was kind of like fake
i think i think like surgeons yeah and
you're
i do want them to make i want them to be
flying first class yeah i want them
they're kids you want their son
i mean just give him something
[Laughter]
we're all laughing at him he's not here
that's great because we do it when he's
here we do when he's gone we treat him
the same when he's here when he's gone
being able to bash carlos is such a
freedom and a joy and i want to just
thank all the listeners for getting it
and understanding oh i want to thank
cockroaches for
really blowing my mind beyond like i'm
already so terrified of them and then i
learned this one fact because sosi bacon
texted me oh god awful article about
cockroaches and what we found out was
not only have they evolved to have two
penises for more um effective copulation
so they're called cockroaches
oh my god um sorry guys i'll stop
interrupting and then you won't get
those jokes
but they have sex for 90
minutes that's my nightmare
that hurts just hearing it
remember the um dave chappelle
sketch wrap it up um so all the more
reason why i think that
um forever be
terrified of them
because you're afraid they'll [ __ ] you
for 90 minutes i mean and then tell you
that your brother then all of a sudden
you find out you're half cockroach i
mean is there is there a freaking study
out there like you know we're like oh
yeah certain mammals have sex for
pleasure have we even measured whether
or not insects or cockroaches have sex
for pleasure because 90 minutes seems
like they're really enjoying it that's a
whole lot of foreplay what is that so we
shouldn't have eaten them right
what's the perfect like number of
minutes for sex
nine
max
15 to 20. really i'm really into it but
it's like i thought it's like i think
like 11 to 14 minutes but don't you like
that it's so low
what do you mean like don't you like
that we're not like an hour but i did i
had a boyfriend where we we like i don't
know what happened honestly it was weird
but it was like fell asleep woke up it
was like cool i guess that is good
so like if you're not chasing the orgasm
and you're just like hey let's [ __ ] just
to [ __ ] and like be clear it was like a
thing and then you stop without pressure
to be like did i make you come did i not
you just sort of like and then you get
back to it later you talk about that and
it's a whole sunday of just [ __ ] and
not [ __ ] in [ __ ] again and not
[ __ ] that's fun and we talk about
this for a second
now word from our sponsor better help
you guys therapy is an indispensable
part of my life it's something that
i've needed a lot of in the last couple
years and i've needed even more of in
the last year there's no shame in the
mental health game there's no shame in
saying you need help or that you feel
burnt out and that you simply need an
unbiased ear to get you through your day
your week your year
i think if you want to invest in
something
that will
absolutely pay off and be worth it it's
to invest in yourself invest in your own
mental health
your brain
needs to be working right and
functioning right for you to have
anything worthwhile in life for you to
appreciate what you have i mean for me
i couldn't appreciate or be grateful for
anything until i got my mind right and
actually
got the help that i needed and also
couldn't accomplish anything without
help you guys i was such in a pit of
anxiety and misery a couple years ago
um i used to not be able to leave the
house or not be outside of like a five
mile radius from a hospital that's how
bad my anxiety was and if it wasn't for
therapy i would still be very much shut
in so if this sounds like something you
relate to
better help is the way to go better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to and
that's a very helpful feature that they
offer and it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours from
right this moment and our listeners get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash trash tuesday our show
would not be in existence if it wasn't
for something like better help
i banged a guy years ago i had this
um
todd does watch the show i love you
tommy
i love you i didn't love you i had to
bang a couple
frogs
[Laughter]
um
but
anyway so
there was this australian guy that came
in to in brooklyn we were at the same
coffee shop we're in line it was like
tall and hot
and um
we just were flirting in line or
whatever and i was just like
my move was always to just be like
you're so hot look at you and he's like
oh you're hot and then we went to this
afro punk festival together
seton smith was performing so i got to
be like that's my friend up there i get
to look cool
but so his deal was that he was
on a hall pass he was getting married he
was an australian uh musician he was 23.
i was like 27 i think his wife or his
fiance at the time was
32 or something a little bit older than
him but she had kind of like snagged
this hot like you know guy who was like
touring and could probably get all the
[ __ ] and stuff like that but he really
loved her and she was like i really want
to get married and have kids i don't
want to like wait around
so you have to decide what you want why
don't you go to america and like
do your thing and then
come up with your we'll meet up in
mexico like they met up in brooklyn they
went to mexico and then they made their
decision or whatever so he's like
telling me all this and i was like oh
well allow me to be your [ __ ] sherpa my
friend
and so we like we hung out like i wasn't
sure what was gonna go down or whatever
but we just really clicked we just
really got along we had such a good time
he was so like cool and respectful and
interesting
and fun like he was just a great guy
and
so we ended up hooking up but we banged
for like
so long and then i was like i'm like did
you come like i started to feel so
insecure about like did he come or not
and then i never asked him
um
[Music]
i think he did
or maybe i did i was like no i came
already and then i kept [ __ ] you is
that a thing guys do
yeah some guys 23 [ __ ] yeah
so he just kept going and then but i was
like
in my head the whole time like oh my god
and then he um and then we went out he
came to one of my shows i was doing a
show in brooklyn oh so there was a real
connection we were friends it was like
cool we like really liked each other but
so that and then and he was kind of
talking to this girl and i was like
full permission obviously you're on your
hall pat whatever you want to do and
he's like no i want to hang out with you
and i don't think we banged like we just
hung out
and then um
years later and then he so
like a couple years later he dm'd me
because then he was like oh my
girlfriend's coming like sorry we can't
like hang out anymore like awesome
fine thank you fun time he dm'd me like
a couple years later and was like hey i
just want to let you know like i we did
decide to get married and
and um we had a kid and i was like did
you name it after me and um
and then he was like but i just really
wanted to like let you know i just like
like i keep meeting you
he's like i love meeting you it wasn't
sexual which keeps making me think she
didn't come here
nobody was like i just like loved
hanging out it was so cool he's like
that was so fun so like that's such a
positive story yeah it was cute i really
like that you know it it kind of makes
me think of this dating advice that i
got from one of the fancy rich moms i
babysat for in beverly hills where when
i was having it's a lesson that i
learned that i now i know and of grasp
but i wish i would have taken it in
earlier in my 20s where she was like
you have to keep the guy on a long leash
like
let them go like and because i don't
know i just it made me think that when
he said he was talking to another girl
and even the woman he ended up marrying
she was like go like you
i clinged so hard and so tight to every
[ __ ] guy that i talked to like
up until probably like literally
ten years into the day you were such a
liar i don't know i know
ten years into dating dave but like the
long leash it works like you go go have
fun go do your thing like that will make
them come back but the issue i think i
think the reason it worked in this
situation well it didn't he didn't come
i mean he married another woman
there was no expectations it was like it
was i've had a couple i had one guy that
i hooked up with and i had we had no
like it was just gonna be like
uh like an affair type thing like not
like nobody was dating anyone but it was
just like when you really go in and
you're like i promise you that this is
not this is just about like i like you
want to get to know you but i'm not like
really looking for anything now that is
like the most powerful
fun time but when i like want someone to
be my boyfriend
i i have trouble being like if i'm
saying you have a long leash i'm lying
yeah and then i'm like still like
nervous
especially at that age because i was not
securely attached at all
like i wanted to be the very best in his
eyes i wanted to be the one that really
like you know i i wanted to be
everything a sister a lover a cousin
an aunt
i i um this girl on tick tock everything
all my references
look at my nose it's a butt nose i love
that it's not that it's
amazing it's the future but basically
she said um something that really hit
home for me which was um people who are
um not securely attached are actually
the most emotionally unavailable
because i
i'm like so desperate when i like
someone it's just like
i'll do anything to make it work and she
takes it away and
that's that's how i've been i have um
pedal to the metal this fear of like i
always rush to commitment yeah because
i'm so afraid of
having these big feelings without
reciprocation that i need it immediately
and i've never learned to like slow down
yeah i've never learned to date someone
for months it's always been like and
thankfully bobby was very similar he you
know he was just like all right you're
my girlfriend yeah like oh okay good
like it worked out right well yeah
because i also do a thing where it's
like i need the guy to tell me what's go
like do you like me or not like i need
to know right away but i don't even know
yet like i don't know if i like them
right like i like i've been i mean there
was that one guy i mean their guy was
like i would this was not my person i
mean it was like there was guys that i
was in like toxic things with where it
was like okay maybe this is my person
we're like
we have some of the hilarities throwing
dishes we're like trump um
but it was like there was one guy where
was like i didn't even i was like i
don't even think you're like my guy but
i was like you must tell me you like me
you must tell me like i just needed it
so bad for me i feel like dave and i
were almost in such different
relationships like he was slowly dating
me and i in my head was like we're
married we're married thankfully like i
slowly learned to
like your fake engagement is everything
i [ __ ] tricked him into
getting engaged i have no interest in
getting married well no that it's like i
was literally from day one desperate to
get engaged to him desperate from year
one to year six like it's all i thought
i wanted it so badly that once i got it
i was almost like oh i can breathe
breathe and enjoy this you were anxious
that he might leave you right yeah so
once the ring's on you're like there we
go exactly like i trusted the ring like
for some whatever it is like that was
enough for me he was always into you too
it's so funny he was always so into you
i know and i know and he would always
say things to me like we will do those
things but it it just went in when
you're not the other because i was so
anxiously attached
um
i actually read a comment that
really was interesting and i want to
tell you guys about it um so last week i
said
that i maybe wouldn't want to have sex
with a guy who had hooked up with a lot
of girls because like he won't
appreciate it and someone commented
well that's like
you always say that guys slut-shamed
girls for hooking up with a lot of
guys like why you're kind of doing the
same thing to guys and it really had me
thinking like are they right am i right
and i just want like what do you guys
think of that is that is it slut-shaming
to not want to be with a guy who's
hooked up with a lot of girls
or
it like is that hypocritical because i
feel like it is but it also isn't but
but if you are not a [ __ ] girl
and why would you [ __ ] a [ __ ] boy
do you know what i mean like were you
looking to just bang someone
no this isn't based on a specific it's
like
is it okay for me to judge guys who
[ __ ] up with a lot of girls
but also guess not i mean what are your
reasons though what are it depends on
their reasons if you're like
i can tell you from someone who is
with bobby he's been with hundreds and
hundreds and countless of women and
he um
my biggest fear in all of that was
what am i getting here like that
i'm rolling the dice on stds and things
like that so i was very careful about
making sure that you know there was
testing and all of that
um
but that's my biggest fear because i
have a big fear of sexually transmitted
diseases
because that's somehow like you know how
bert kreischer was talking about that's
a ocd thing he has in his head that's
something that i obsess about a lot i
feel like everyone does that don't you
right
obsesses about it dude i like not all
because i have some some some friends
who really just like raw dog with
absolute abandon and they're just like
who cares oh my god antibiotics whatever
like they really are okay without it um
i i have that weird compulsion and
obsession it does not leave my head so
that would be my reason to give me pause
but it actually
it uh it makes me feel better to know
that they have absolutely drained their
balls to the point where i'm like you've
had it all
and now we're in a relationship you're
never gonna you're never gonna be like
you know what i have
i wonder about having sex with this
person this person i'm like no you
[ __ ] 400 people
can we just say no can i say no you know
that's an interesting i hadn't thought
about that perspective because when i
had originally said what i said it was
more like i never wanted to hook up with
guys who had been with a lot of women if
i knew they had because then i wouldn't
feel so that's not you yeah it's like
not about you're not like you didn't
mean to be judging them you were more
like it's not it's not my preference but
esther isn't it more of a compliment to
know that a man has been with a thousand
women and somehow he's chosen you
but she just means
right
i don't know what i mean but that is
like i'm interested in that perspective
i don't know that's how i see it at
least like oh wow i like that you chose
my [ __ ] out of the plethora of [ __ ]
the standard [ __ ] yeah the very
standard average [ __ ] i just think
yeah i always i'm like
kind of sad if i date a guy and he's not
like he wasn't as sexually active as
ma'am i was like oh
i wanted to be match i'm i'm a twin i'm
i'm going to be matchy with you i'm
going to wear the same track suits and
have the same track record i find it hot
when dudes when if i
i don't know what's wrong with me maybe
i'd come i'm kind of a cuck in that way
i like listening to um dudes that i like
talk about exes and it kind of this is
fire in my chest and it burns a little
and i get that yeah it like makes you
get a little hot like there's a little
jealousy competition thing but also to
that comment which i'm i'm appreciative
of it because it at least got me
thinking but
traditionally society slut-shames women
and they don't do it to men yeah men are
like so i'm kind of like okay with being
like let's not slut-shame men and it's
okay that i don't and that's let's not
slut-shame women
and also that doesn't mean that i have
to
like guys also you're not wrong because
men don't feel shame about
banging a whole lot of women is there
even a way to [ __ ] shame a man no this
whole
patriarchy doesn't allow for him to feel
shame really we might i don't know it's
like there's case by case there's gotta
be good well write us write us if you're
a guy who's ever felt shamed for being
with a lot of women will you like write
one of us and tell us you're excited
i have a guy that i'm friends with who i
do comedy with and
he um doesn't not try snitching on
anyone
i promise i promise but um he um
used to get a lot of [ __ ] like if you
ask people like at the comedy store like
who got the most [ __ ] back in the day
they always say him but now he's
literally he's engaged he's like it's
done annie i'm done i'm so happy to be
done with that part of my life i'm in
love i can't wait to just get married i
have so many guy friends who are not
they sleep around but they're not happy
about it it's like filling a void i'm
telling you it's that thing of not
getting banged in in high school yeah
where it's like they feel like they have
to like they don't want to like be like
like ungrateful to the [ __ ] they're now
getting well sex addition addiction is
real yeah it's sad
i don't think they feel like full in the
end or like happy in the end they're
chasing a high it's very dark and and so
i think i think there should be grace on
that and i think that
you know we just don't know what people
are thinking i was thinking that when i
was watching the card the new
kardashians season um when they're
talking about tristan thompson and how
like how could he do this and all this
stuff and in my head i'm like the man
has a problem yeah he's i bet he doesn't
want to do that he's addicted he can't
help himself like that's not an excuse
but
but like yeah i feel like with athletes
and people that are like in the a lot of
those guys are just they're also like
they're just getting [ __ ] thrown at
them too
yeah i think like about michael jackson
and like he's like the person i think of
as like a victim of like fahim was on
tiger belly this past week and we talked
a lot about michael jackson and i think
what you
what you're about to say is exactly what
i said which is you understand why
someone like that who was raised like
that would eventually
desire the company of a child in his bed
because he was in an arrested
development he was never allowed to grow
up everything had been done for him
served hand and foot it's like of course
he was warped his entire world was
warped you can wrap your head around the
idea that someone like that allegedly
could be a pedophile well there are
pedophiles who try to not be pedophiles
you know there are pedophiles that are
victims of being this thing who like get
their balls cut off and go live in woods
where there are no kids like there are
people that try their hardest to not
pray so it's like i don't want to be
like completely have no compassion for
pedophiles
because obviously there are ones that
are just like cursed with this thing or
things were done to them yeah but it is
just it is a [ __ ] up thing when you
when your thing hurts other people it's
not okay look having my dog julio who is
a full-blown psychopath has really
taught me
um to
um have compassion for everyone and
anyone no matter how
depraved they are only because it's like
not compassion like i excuse their
behavior but it's almost like a a [ __ ]
like
whatever led them there was probably not
good yeah in the case of julio he was
born
without a mother i mean um
as an orphan without siblings and likely
with a [ __ ] up brain because he didn't
have the nutrients he needed as a
newborn and i look at him and he cannot
help himself when i see him start to
kind of get a little bit like aggressive
i can see that he keeps looking at me
for reassurance but he goes ahead and
bites anyways baby and it's like he
cannot help who he is and it is so
[ __ ] up and the bites hurt and i cry
and i it's it's a very hard thing to
love julio but i understand julio and i
think that
you know not to say it's like oh we have
compassion for psychopaths that murder
people or do all of these things but
it's more of an understanding yeah all
right you were built very different than
me yeah i had when my teacher when i had
the thing happen with my teacher and he
was like he spent his one night in jail
tonight cool in prison for years um
you just me into a prison hard to get
out of but i turned it around
um
his wife called me threatening me
screaming at me all this stuff then her
next tactic was to call she was married
yeah no she was there um they were
grooming us the whole they had us all
going over to their house buying us weed
and alcohol and stuff getting naked with
us
yeah
i was on a whole skin and it didn't blow
up because
what i realized is
when you're a kid people tell you that
they want you to tell the truth and what
i've learned more and more in my life
which i'm trying to be okay with and not
judge it people do not want you to tell
the truth people want you to do the
thing that's the easiest for everyone to
move forward it doesn't make people feel
uncomfortable and i'm coming to terms
with that in my life now where it's like
what's worth it what's not but it's like
in that situation i'm very proud of what
i did because i do think i stopped him
from praying on other people
it's just
um it's just a weird time it's a weird
time of the row versus way it's just a
weird time it's like
what you know kind of like picking my
battles
and i did realize in the end people did
not want that my parents like signed a
plea deal like i mean it's just like
this guy got off with nothing for what
he did and i guess like whatever that's
if i had been older i could have like
gone further with it but that's okay
oh my god we love the new liquid death
flavors
i love lime dave loves berry
oh my god he's been mixing the berry
with cranberry juice it's so good
but have you tried the mango chainsaw
um
you guys we love liquid death we love
their merch we love the fact that it's
death to plastic okay
we want to be drinking out of cans we
want to look cool at parties and we want
people to be like what are what who who
is that crazy person with that can and
if you're that person like me when you
go into like any social event and you're
like i don't know what to do with my
hands but i don't want to carry a drink
because i don't really drink this is the
perfect solution to that you look like a
freaking i know you esther everywhere i
see you with that tall boy
it just completes your look it's so
weird but it really does
um
and the best part is that it's not beer
it's not
crap it's water from
the alps i don't know actually mountain
spring water from the out thank you
guys they have new flavors mango
chainsaw the one that's in my hand right
now severed lime the one that esther's
drinking and bury it alive and all of
their flavors have three grams of agave
nectar in them i love them because it's
like just a hint of sweet a hint of
flavor not overpowering you can still
feel good about it i love to do combos
so you guys can go to liquiddeth.com
trash to get free shipping on their
crazy limited edition merch and apparel
that's liquiddeth.com trash to get free
shipping on their limited edition merch
and apparel
liquid death
death of plastic
murder your thirst
[Music]
but yeah no it's just a weird time i
don't know it's weird it's like
i don't
you know we it's like but also are we
getting in trouble when we say things is
there an actual trouble is it just
people's like interpretations of what
we're saying and stuff is there an
actual trouble is it like
do you know what i mean i don't want to
speak too specifically about things
because
it's just like i think what you said is
right it's a weird time it's like i sit
here and we have these honest
conversations and i'm like who's gonna
be mad that they take this out of
context and what do they think or like
even just the episode that came out last
week um
there were so many dm's to the trash
tuesday instagram that i heard about
that were like you didn't talk about roe
v wade and it's like why are you jumping
down our throats for
for thinking that we don't like how you
must not have ever listened to this show
if you think because one episode came
out and we didn't talk about something
current because it was recorded before
like you're just attacking us for that
like yeah what do you think we think
about abortion also the thing is that
um
though we like love you guys and we're
here to entertain you and to like have
this open discussion with you guys we're
not here living for you we are ourselves
we are here like having our day doing
what we want to do and hoping that that
is that's my like i hope that you
see that we're doing that and doing
living fearlessly and just saying our
[ __ ] and that you can be inspired by
that you are not different from a man
telling me to stop saying something you
are not different if you're telling me i
have to speak out on something you're
not different from a guy telling me i
have to stop speaking about something
it's the same thing yes but it's my job
to not take that on and to know that
those people are just having their
reaction to roe versus wade they're
having their own feelings about it and
their way of feeling like they're doing
something is yelling at
celebrities
hey girls thanks for thinking that you
can control us because we're slabs um
but you know it is like it's our job to
not like take they're just going through
their feelings and it's yeah okay i like
it yeah
it's like and we we [ __ ] pre-record
guys you saw us kill rayota
we probably made reverses when it
happened i made a joke and i [ __ ]
probably made it happen you know why i
think you're correct is because in that
episode esther's like abortion's not
illegal yet and then the next day
roe v wade it's my fault we're witches
we did it again
it's fun to be powerful even if it's for
negative negative consequences there's
some deaths we saved some babies lives
and we killed one man okay
oh yeah
i don't know if yeah you know i know
that um that's part of the sport we play
is
you know giving a lot of our
personal lives up for consumption that's
the bed we made we lay on it right there
are some perks to that
we lay there we really do just lay there
too
we we just lay like princesses
yeah so like you know for me having done
tiger belly for
so long i i do know the bed i made for
so many years i over shared and i said
all of these things and bobby and i put
our relationship out there for
consumption
and
but i think that
what people sometimes don't
where i feel like sometimes a little
trapped is
we're not allowed to grow and change our
mind about things yeah what you thought
of me when i was 29 years old and
talking on dvdsa or an episode three of
tiger belly is just not who i am anymore
and
i guess all of this to say like
there are some things that i really like
want to get off my chest
i had committed to
not
saying any more than what's already been
said in regards to my relationship with
bobby just because it is
scary to put your stuff out there i know
that now i know that
i am not as charming or as likable or as
funny as bobby and people really rally
behind
a very lovable because he is he's he
comes off as and he that's not he
doesn't come off that way he is that way
like he's i love him to death in the
same way that you guys love him i love
him too but there's this story
that is so
twisted
and warped and so wrong that's being
said about me that i just really want to
clarify if that's okay yeah
um bobby and i on age three went and we
talked about being in an open
relationship but the way we explained it
was so poor because we were so it was
number one it was a live show number two
we didn't even know that we had to even
say it in that moment or talk about and
then we went on tiger belly and again we
explained it poorly
because i wasn't present he said you
know it just it was poorly explained
and there's this
idea that
i was the one who asked for an open
relationship
but the truth is and you guys know this
i am not the one who asked for an open
relationship
and that's a [ __ ] fact i am not the
person who instigated initiated even
thought of that as
a realm of [ __ ] possibility for my
relationship
the truth of that is
bobby
was
i intercepted something alluding to
bobby and another woman in hawaii
and
that is even how the conversation ended
up
to having an open relationship i didn't
instigate it i didn't start it i didn't
cheat
bobby can corroborate the story we could
probably talk about it in a different
time in a clearer way when things aren't
so like high pressure on [ __ ] live h3
um i didn't do that i simply didn't
[ __ ] do that and
if we did move into that space of an
open relationship just because you know
about what i did
doesn't mean that bobby didn't go ahead
and do what he did
with whoever he did
i just chose
to not know
he chose to ask me that information i
gave him openly said this is what i've
done
i chose i opted out of knowing that
information it doesn't mean that he
didn't take advantage of being in an
open relationship as well
and
i am so just
like
that [ __ ] hurts me you guys because i
feel like here i have this mic but i
can't even like tell you my truth
because i feel like that truth is going
to be twisted somehow and i understand
that you guys
want
a villain in this story and it makes
life easier to understand when you have
bad guy good guy and i understand that
i have made a lot of mistakes in the
last eight years of my relationship with
bobby i'm complicit in that but there
are two people here
there really are we have
loved each other extensively and deeply
but we have also [ __ ] each other up in
a lot of ways
and
i'm exhausted
it's so annoying it frustrates me almost
hearing you say this because like
i just feel like i'm so convinced that
no one is gonna listen like because
there's so many comments like saying
these things about you and it's like
do they even care to hear the truth
i have to like resist writing people i
want to like write people back and be
like that's not what [ __ ] happened
and also this all stemmed from us trying
to tell like a thing that we experienced
do you know what you mean but and then
it turned into this whole thing and then
it's like
it's so easy to be like the cheating
[ __ ] i know and like poor bobby this
innocent little thing where it's like
bobby doesn't need you to think he's an
innocent little thing he's a 50 year old
[ __ ] man okay he's a grown ass
successful [ __ ] man he was on mad tv
you [ __ ] idiots like he was on [ __ ]
when you were [ __ ] two years old so
stop like it's like infantilizing him
it's like making him this tiny little
thing and it's like look people get hurt
we all have been like in a weird
stressful [ __ ] situation no
and it's like kalila's getting this hit
that is like crazy it's crazy and it's
like we shouldn't care about comments we
shouldn't care about that but what the
[ __ ] guys
what the [ __ ]
um
i um
i said i you know we made our bed we
started this whole journey over sharing
and i
am
you know
i'd like a little bit of my life back i
think
and i think that no matter like where i
go or him and i wherever we go
um
the love is permanent
we never grew apart we grew
even closer
but in what capacity we choose to move
forward in this life together where
whether it's a couple
whether it's
just you know close family whether it's
a business partner
i um
i just um
don't think that i
want to give so much of that away
anymore
because i do love him
and i i
for once in my life like i wanna protect
what we have which i wasn't doing for a
very long time i realized that now i
gave so much away i wasn't protecting we
weren't protecting what we had
we were giving it up for people to
consume
but um yeah i'm [ __ ] up over it well
also it's like i feel like you're in
this position where it's like you at
least a position perceived because i
guess we're all like
listening to outside sources or whatever
but it's like you feel like you have to
like defend yourself all the time and
it's like
the even the reason you came out with it
on h3 is because you felt like you were
being threatened and you had to like
come out with it
you know and then it's like you come out
with it and then you're like attacked
even more and it's just like what are we
supposed to do here it's almost like is
there a [ __ ] gender war really guys
yeah is that really happening because
not on this show no not on this show
yeah
there's not on this show and i you know
we've met all the people there it's like
we have boy slugs girl slugs it's like
and i read the comments last week our
last week's comments were really good
they really were thank you oh pete good
timing with a banana
[Music]
you know what i love about you pete yeah
there's that there's a third person here
who's a hypocrite
he says he wasn't molested but you were
molested i think something happened in
your childhood petey i gotta think about
it
maybe what what a privilege he's gotta
think about it do you have a jaw thing
no
okay you're fine it's better just not to
remember
do
[Laughter]
oh should i call carlos oh yeah let's
call carlos let's interrupt his vacation
carlos can never be mad at us before
calling him gay every day we include him
in everything
he knows no we don't care carlos doesn't
get a vacation
he's trying he blocked my number
flies to mexico
i will show up
and ask him to tie my shoe
[Laughter]
lois
how's
how is
hi sir oh you paused what's going on
carlos
how is your first class mexican vacation
it's good i'm eating tacos in my room
right now you better not be eating the
uh tortilla
of course not of course not he's just
eating the meat out guys
carlos gets it he would not have eaten
that cupcake either
carlos
um how was first class what flight was
it what airline
it was alaska burbank to cabo and i had
um
overnight oats and everyone around me
had sausage
like biscuit breakfast sandwiches and i
was like hell no no no no
that's why they're getting two first
class seats right and you're only
getting one wait you grew out of burbank
you little [ __ ] burbank's the best the
best
i live so close to lax though
don't stalk me
i live in the terminal
how's the episode going did you talk
about roe v wade yet
um we got kind of intense at times we
cried all three of us cried we actually
all cried because we miss you
i'm gone and you're crying yeah
i choked it back a little though i was
like
don't let them see you
um how's your nephew
he's super cute
um he's cool
and uh he's getting all the attention
which is a little annoying but i hate
that i hate that okay having esther get
all the attention your other little
nephew
[Laughter]
all right we'll let you america's little
nephew esther
all right i miss you girls
bye we miss you
i think next time you and bobby open
your relationship you should both only
be allowed to [ __ ] carlos
[Laughter]
i think that's what i'm your new
therapist
if we were artists like we're putting
our art is like talking in these
conversations and putting these things
out like you don't really get to have a
say and how people interpret your art
once it's out there so it's like maybe
we do just need to really detach from
and it sucks we
i do i swear reading the comments is
like i want to like
see what you guys think and
get a take but it's like maybe we do
just have to completely detach and just
like
i think it for me it goes in flow you
know
like sometimes i have to completely
detach from things rumors and comments
and reddits and and then sometimes i'm
like oh i'm feeling really secure and i
can dig around and find oh that's
interesting you know i think like it'll
just like everything in life like it's
always going to be
up and down and change and flow well
bobby
funny enough gave me the best advice in
all of this because i was like i feel
like i can't even bobby i can't even
speak my truth i can't even like say
what i want to say in all of this and he
was like the more they speculate the
better
for everyone
and i'm like it doesn't feel that way
it doesn't feel that way he was like
kalila he's like
just it none of it matters it matters
that we continue to podcast every week
side by side that we love each other
that we're kind to each other that we're
not abusive to each other he's like we
have our truth whatever
truth that everyone comes up with
outside of here
he's like it doesn't matter it's click
click click click click speculate write
that shitty comment of yours write that
shitty comment but it's like no matter
what they you still take up real estate
in their mind right and that ultimately
he's like that's the biggest win he's
like you could clarify
the truth if you want he's like but it's
not necessary it's also he's he also
assured me it wasn't going to stop the
hate and he's right it's not gonna
i mean i'm doing it just because i just
need to get it off maybe we could take
some of it
but but you know what he's he's right
he's right but he's operating in like
i'm a businessman yeah well that's like
superstar level like how do you think
[ __ ] kris jenner talks to her
daughters it's like that like
and i i appreciate and like that like
that is
like you say we did make this bed we
have this show we put our lives out
there the show is very popular more
popular than maybe we would have thought
um and and growing yeah and like
so when i do have like those little
moments and there's a dumois and there's
this and that about me and anyone that i
love and care about who are real people
um we're all real people we wake up
every morning whatever like
um we drink our coffee
i just have to go like
kim kardashian everybody hates
there's probably moments where she feels
like everyone hates her but she still
wakes up she goes to her skin's meeting
and like
kisses her kids and eats dinner and has
a great [ __ ] life and like that's
i if she can do it i can handle these
the little bits that we have to deal
with yeah it's like
right like what because what else am i
what else are we gonna do what are we
gonna stop being ourselves to like
appease people we've never met yeah and
and if you think about it right you hear
an hour
of us talking 24 times 7 is what andy i
want to ask you
but that's how many esther's blinking
trying to figure it out
168. what is that 24 times 7 168. so did
you do that in your head it's you out of
168
hours that we live weekly
out of here you're judging us for one
hour in a room together like you don't
know what
we do like really at the end of the day
you don't really know who we are you
know the worst parts of us because we
throw it on the screen for you you know
the things that have hurt us along the
way you know the people that we love
kinda sorta but do you really know todd
do you really know how well he takes
care of annie outside of what she's
already said or like you know like what
what that looks like you know what what
bobby and i what it feels like to sit
and watch like a shitty baking show with
bobby like you don't know that that's
167 hours unaccounted for that you will
never know us in that way you know
there's an elephant in the room that we
haven't even addressed which is that
i'm wearing skims all
the people who [ __ ] get it yes no i'm
people too yeah we meet on the road who
we run into at the coffee shop who
[ __ ] get it all the positive comments
like
the there are
like we also
more
than the bad there's way more good
because i was thinking about the comment
reading i was like what am i doing here
what is this coming from this is
obviously not like like why am i like
because todd's like you'll go until you
get a negative one like you'll get all
these like positive ones and then you
like want this like hit of like dopamine
of like pain of
feeling like you know a victim or
feeling like someone doesn't get you or
whatever and i was thinking i was like
no why you know i have this story in my
head where it's like no i'm going there
to like see
what people think and make sure but it's
not because if i'm going there for the
conference i get them in person the
shows are [ __ ] amazing i can promise
you if you come to my show you're going
to laugh your ass off the entire hour
you're going to love my openers you're
going to wait in a meet and greet line
i'm going to talk to you we're going to
have a [ __ ] amazing conversation
if you want if you want to wait and if
you want to buy a shirt i'm going to
sign it we're going to have a personal
we're going to have like our own inside
like i'm meeting these people connecting
with them it's so fun it's so cool they
[ __ ] love you guys they it's like
it's all good vibes it's never bad yeah
so it's like if you want to see the good
part of this come see our [ __ ] shows
like come see us we're gonna get this
[ __ ] on the road i promise
tell your friends about the show like
yeah so it's so fun it's like amazing
it's really cool what the show has done
and i do think that like i think that
boy and girl slugs are gonna [ __ ]
change the world i know that sounds so
dramatic but i really do i think that
like
it's amazing that guys are sitting here
listening to us
blah blah blah yeah it's awesome
the demographic um breakdown of this
show is half female half man it's
amazing
it's a dream cool like who else can say
that like
yeah i i think it's so awesome and i'm
so proud of this show you know what i
noticed this is so cheesy but like this
morning i was looking at everybody's
instagrams and we all have
tagged in our instagram bios trash
tuesday and i'm like we're all so proud
of this yeah like we created this
there's
nothing
of this is anything but the three of us
like this is our baby our brain child
like i don't know there's so much
positive too and it sucks that there's
this negative thing happening but that's
also okay right we're still here we're
so [ __ ] happy that you found us and
we found you like
yeah and also if it's a little price to
pay to be like three women who are just
kind of
being ourselves then that's the price we
pay
yeah you know
oh well we can take it to keep doing it
it's like what are we gonna do not be
ourselves right like that and i really
love on the road i'm sure you get the
slot too where the couples will come up
and they'll be like the girl will be
like he got me into yeah it's like yes
[ __ ] yes it's a lot of like oh
so my boyfriend always listen to
podcasts and then this one came out and
he was like you need to know this one
because it's girls like and then and
then i then she became a podcast fan
like
that's other thing and this goes for
mostly with stand-up but i think podcast
too like it is a predominantly male yeah
driven field like i'm predominantly male
as well so it works like stand-up was a
most mostly guys podcasting mostly guys
so i'm we are acquiring listeners who
have never listened to podcasts before
and i think that's like part of the
mission that we always talk about it's
like
we're
i don't know we're just like creating
this for women yeah but also for guys
but we're like so excited that guys are
and it's i'll see like groups of women
like there are these three australian
women at the comedy store and i was like
come to my podcast come to me like
follow this and they all like got their
phones and i was like we made this for
you like you're gonna love it like to
just know that people are gonna like it
it's just so cool i love your man on the
street one-on-one marketing like
well i just see i'm like you're gonna
have this
yes join us
it's true follow us
anyways
that got real um serious but thank you
guys for tuning in this week